well joining me now is former star of
sasu Des Williams at Middleton organizer
of BLM protests Iman eight well welcome
to both of you
um
and we also sorry down the line we have
Royal correspondent Vanity Fair okay
I'll start with Katie Nicole um Katie
thanks for joining me
I gotta say the nearer we get to This
Global event as Netflix call it which is
going to be Unleashed on Thursday
morning at 8 A.M with the first three
episodes the more angry I'm becoming
about what this is going to do to a
grieving Monarch who's not even been
coronated yet to replace his mother to
the new Prince of Wales trying to build
that position now for himself and his
wife and his children uh all of it makes
me puke that these two once again are
going to be reigning muck all over their
families not just for the global
titillation but for hard dollars 80
million dollars which is why they're
doing it
absolutely and I can only imagine for
the king for the Prince of Wales I mean
they must just have their heads in their
hands
um exasperated frustrated hurt betrayed
angry all words that I've been told are
the feelings behind closed doors at the
palace um you know who knows whether
they're going to be tuning in when the
first three episodes of this docu-series
drop on Thursday I suspect the Royal
lawyers will be watching very closely
I'm sure the courtiers will be watching
closely particularly those who claim
they were bullied by Megan The Duchess
of Sussex and I think the problem with
all of this is is so clearly highlighted
in those very controversial trailers is
it is so partisan it is so one-sided and
I suspect will come away saying exactly
what we said after the Oprah interview
well where were the counter questions
where you know where are the Tabloid
editors who can put another side of the
argument across they say they want to
put across their truth but is it the
truth well we know after Oprah is
nowhere near the truth um at Middleton
you've always been very supportive of
Harry I think the military connection
obviously and there's no doubt you know
this this guy served his country with
honor
um in war zones and he deserves great
credit for that my brother-in-law taught
him at Santos Military Academy said he
was a fine young Soldier nothing could
take that away from him uh but what I've
I detect from people I know in the
military is an unbelievable
disappointment in what he's now becoming
and the fact that of course when you
serve the military you serve them oath
to you know serve your country and your
Monarch yes and here he is just now
constantly attacking his father who's
the new king and the monarchy the
institution I think when people are fed
up with being suffocated by wokeness and
by a uh you know an attention-seeking
manner like they they have been
um you can't defend them anymore you
know having I defend them all along said
look he's protected his country served
his country he should go off like they
wanted to go off and live their life
outside of the media outside the
Limelight privacy with waiting for the
media and I completely respected that I
thought to myself you know what the man
served this country let him get away
they didn't mean to but to then do the
complete opposite not the complete
opposite discreetly the complete
opposite in the face in our faces not
only the people of our of his country
which we we did look at him as our
Prince but also the monarchy you know I
served the monarchy I swore Allegiance
yeah you know I fought for Harry for
William for the queen for the king I
fought for those people
um during you know during a couple of
decades so when I see now that I've not
only defended them but he's come out and
the wokeness behind it the virtual
signaling behind this is is sickening
now people I think people have got to
the point where they're they're fed up
with hearing the same old but also and
then making money out of it well it's
also it's also hypocrisy and lies right
in the two trailers which last no more
than two and a half minutes between them
already six of the images that they have
used in the trailers to illustrate the
intrusion into their lives have been
proven to be the complete opposite
either they weren't at the events which
are being depicted like one's a Harry
Potter Premiere five years before they
met or their official photo calls were
the pictures they've used were actually
from people who'd been officially
approved to stand there and take those
pictures of the Royals to promote them
what's very obvious in here peers what's
very obvious here is there's a there's a
there's a toxic partner in this
relationship and we know who it is you
know Harry is not the person that he is
now when you look at the two differences
of what she's slightly manipulated
I'm going to come to you pushing this
woman
I'm going to come to you you are she by
the way she by the way is unloading a
load of manure all over her family over
the next 48 hours one moment it's going
to finish on one point about the lying
is one thing the hypocrisy these two go
on about carbon footprint about the
environment and where do they wash up to
get this award in another private plane
I mean to me again they say one thing
they preach one thing but they do the
complete opposite right the stage is
yours thank you give me one good reason
why we shouldn't be feeling this way
about these okay you know what I'm going
to start with the first point because
I've had to listen to load of people
vilify this woman all day every day and
you know what I'm fed up with it so
first points okay so the
commercialization of the rift within the
royal family is a byproduct okay a
byproduct of the institution's failure
to be anti-racist and Cooperative which
has ultimately led to a series of Savvy
business deals and strategic Maneuvers
on their parts in order to ensure the
safety and security of their family what
you both fail to understand secondly
institutionalized racism when pertaining
to institutionalized racism when an
individual needs help try to seek help
and realize that there is no one to turn
to what you'll often find and you should
know this as a journalist what you
oftentimes mind is that person will seek
solace in the media and press hold on a
second hold on in an attempt to Garner
support build awareness understanding
and Inspire action and all of these
typical circumstances would be perfectly
okay
but for some reason it's not but we
don't disagree with that we don't
disagree with that any normal sounds
it's not for this particular couple now
hold on let's just bear that in mind I
want to ask you one thing about what you
just said okay where is the evidence
that she went to people at the palace
and they refused to give her help who
were these people nearly two years later
we still don't have any names okay
nothing right now you're holding on to
the fact that she won't give names and
I've already told you that I think she's
a liar hold on a second right I think
she's a bad face
saying that she's a liar yes but right
so let me just say this firstly she said
her son
she said well I'm going to say why I
call her a liar she said to Oprah
Winfrey her son had not been made a
prince because of his skin color
absolute lie okay so that this is what
okay by virtue of the fact that you've
come out with that uh opinion or thought
it shows me that you have a very
rudimentary understanding of racism so
let me break it down to both of you hold
on a second no hold on a second hold on
a second
okay the reason institutions are able to
perpetuate racism is because they rely
heavily on Covert racism which is hard
to prove therefore it thrives let me
just break it down some more because you
clearly don't understand covert racism
is racial Prejudice that is subtle and
discreet and often uh disguised and
rationalized with an alternative
explanation
100 I think any normal what do you mean
that's not right that's not right racism
full stop it should be Stamped Out
absolutely but you don't even understand
it by virtue of the fact
I do understand you don't understand
one thing
perpetuated
but you're getting into the nitty-gritty
of things now what nitty-gritty
excuse me
my show your show here's my point my
point about Megan and Harry they say all
this stuff without producing any
evidence and you wouldn't support it but
you wouldn't let me finish I've already
just explained to you covert racism is
racial Prejudice that is uh uh subtle
and discreet now hold on a second
let me explain this is what I'm trying
to explain to you and you won't let me
finish so let me finish you'll be able
to raise your point okay okay so
racial prejudice
that is subtle and discreet called
covert racism hold on listen just listen
yourself
you're not understanding because reality
is I can give you an example because
clearly you're not getting it so someone
can come along and say oh I don't like
Megan because she's this she's that
she's a lie she's this she's that when
you're ready is secretly it's actually
hold on a second let me finish please
answer it's actually due to the fact
that Harry who was a royal ended up
marrying a woman from the black
community but you cannot say that out
loud because that has got nothing to do
with oh it is
calm down calm down listen because you
won't listen You'll wait for the next
hour right here's my point about that
nothing I've ever said that's critical
of Meghan Markle has anything to do with
her skin color okay so at best either
subliminal or overt or any other way is
to do with her hypocrisy and her life
hypocrisy because ultimately I also
think lighting also think she's a fake
let me ask you one question front page
of every paper today well most of them
have pictures of her crying in the
trailer for the series do you think
those tears were genuine okay so this is
what I'm not even going to go down well
they're trying to lead on the fact that
just because someone is an actress that
therefore every time that they cry
ing you are implying I do because
ultimately said that and I want to play
you something I want to tell you
something so this is an actress who can
also can come
after this is Meghan Markle
oh
my God it's crazy you're like Megan one
tier left eye go give me three seconds
[Music]
three seconds is all it takes for to cry
and just a quick one on on that piece
he's an
actresses
not in the cold this is how
institutionalized racism works when you
dare to go up to against an institution
due to the fact that they're
perpetuating racial Prejudice
you're trying to pretend that it's
something do you not think people use
that card as well and then vindictive
and manipulative
yeah
look at the front pages there which is
when their engagement was announced yeah
where's the racism
do you remember that was before she
actually said that the institution was
racist and that's my point how
institutionalized racism works is the
military
institutions sorry for just everyone's
chanting that's what happens you accept
there's no racism in those media Pages
because that was before she said that
the institution was racist actually
that's when everyone decided to Pilot
actually what happened as a woman people
began to pile on when she started having
half a million dollar baby showers in
New York and flying back on the Clooney
private plane they started having a
pylon started having a pile on when they
used Elton John's private plane like a
taxi rank was preaching about carbon
footprint they had another pile on where
they had other huge extravagant events
they went to and then when they're
preaching about poverty on their Twitter
account time and again they were caught
being rankly hypocritical that was why
the media coverage began to turn then
there was all the stuff with her father
many people felt that she was
unnecessarily cruel to her father people
have since criticized his own behavior I
accept that but certainly to start with
they ditched him they dropped him
Harry's never met his his father-in-law
in his life
you know he proposed marriage to this
girl knowing what's going to happen and
then doesn't do anything to protect the
father at all and so now she's disowned
him what kind of people but compassion
on their website as they do as being at
the center of their core being when they
live 70 miles away from this guy who has
not got long for this world is in poor
health all he wants to do is meet his
grandchildren and she won't have
anything to do with him that's not
compassionate
yeah and also the hypocrisy and the lies
are not what I think are decent values
in people sorry all of those things seem
to outweigh the fact that a black woman
has said nothing to do with everything
is about racism she has ultimately
turned around and said that that
institution is racist and everyone has
decided to pile on so let me just tell
you in terms of my thoughts at best
these individuals are weak insecure hate
to see a rift and have a positive
Prejudice towards the royal family and
at worst they are a bunch of disgusting
racists who fail to acknowledge their
racial Prejudice and actually find
solace in seeking self-esteem and status
from gases either one or the other
problem here's the problem here's the
problem I would have said exactly the
same thing if she'd been White
exactly the same thing what's the point
that you're trying and actually Kate
Middleton who came in she got criticized
very heavily by the media early on in
that relationship
did her Duty accepted in return for all
the luxury of racism these two content
with racism though where did the racism
come from okay so you're clearly not
understanding no you're not
understanding me where did the racism
come from tell me who was racist and
when okay I'm going to answer to you
okay who and when right let's just start
with everyone who and when okay so let
me answer okay firstly racism as I've
said over the last several years and
I'll say it again racism is firmly
interwoven into the fabric of British
Society due to its historical context
and that wasn't my question and that way
I'm answering your questions that's my
question let me finish who was racist to
Megan and Harry in the British media who
was racist at the palace and when were
they racist can I answer your question
now sure give me one example perfect so
firmly racism is family interwoven into
the fabric of British Society give me an
example secondly I'm going to make sure
I'm going to make an example hold on a
second secondly the royal family smeared
their own name tarnished their own name
by failing to adopt anti-racism stances
I'm giving you the example the British
media being racist or someone in the
palace an example let me finish please
is that okay Pierce thank you very much
so you can answer the question I'm going
to answer the question so in terms of
the institution I'm going to give you
several examples of covert racism
clearly as you don't understand fast
I'm going to I do but I see the flip
side as well
we're gonna have to go to a break
either give me an example I'm giving you
examples but you won't let me see give
me one specific example I'm giving you
examples all right so in terms of media
because this is what happens with you
you're clearly not trying to hear me you
just ask for a fact in terms of the
media we've already seen the clear
distinction between how the media has uh
displayed or or spoken or represented
obviously in terms of how they've
represented you don't have anything yes
they do in terms of uh carry or holding
a baby someone I'm sorry Kate held her
stomach and therefore it was fine Megan
held her stomach and she's a terrible
person must be racist racism no it's
called covert racism that you don't
understand man there is no racism
you can continue to perpetuate your
covert racism
I have to leave it there we've had a
good run at this I don't have any racism
covert or over no you have racial
Prejudice I have no racial Prejudice
racist whatsoever I have none whatsoever
that's what you don't understand I won't
be giving you 21 minutes of my show so
because on a regular basis without a
racial Prejudice what happens so white
people tend to justify either sleeping
with a black person having a black
friend and or hiring a black person as
to um
if you can provide some facts behind
which I did extremely excited yes I'm
trying to say everyone's racist in
Britain but I can't give you a single
example
she already experienced Lisa institution
I already told you that woman just I
know I'm a gaslighting covert racist
thank you very much you are indeed all
right great to see you thank you